in this lesson we're going to talk about
the law of cosines now the law of
cosines has shown up on previous act
tests and usually when it does they give
you the formula so it's not something
that you have to memorize but it's
something that you need to know how to
use so
when you use the law of cosines it's
when you have a triangle that's not a
right triangle so it doesn't have that
right angle in there and you know to use
the law of cosines when you are only
given three sides side side side or just
side angle side you have the angle in
between the two known lengths of those
sides
so here's the three different forms
you can usually just memorize one of
them is what i do but you can see the
pattern here you've got c squared equals
a squared plus b squared just like
pythagorean theorem minus two a b cosine
c now notice the side c and the angle c
they're across from each other in the
formula they're also across from each
other in the triangle so in the triangle
the capital letters are the angles and
then the sides across from those angles
those are the sides and you can see
that's given a lowercase letter so you
can see angle a side a angle c side c
okay so same thing here you can see in
this variation of the form they have
side b and angle b okay they're across
from each other in the triangle and
they're also across from each other in
the formula and then you can see a and c
a and c those are the two sides that
make up that angle same thing here
you've got side a and angle a okay
they're across from each other in the
triangle across from each other in the
formula and then the other two
quantities b and c b and c those are the
two sides that make up that angle so
let's go through an example you can see
how this works so
i usually give you an example like this
where they have you find the distance
between two objects say for example you
have two planes they leave the airport
at the same time at a 10 degree angle
from each other one travels two miles
one travels three miles how far apart
are they uh go ahead and find that
distance so pause the video see if you
can do this one we'll go through it
together
so in this example let's just use this
first formula here so let's just say
that this is side c here this is angle c
here and then what we'll do is we'll
make this uh
angle b and we'll make this side b and
we'll make this angle a will make this
side a so what we're going to do is
we're going to use this first formula
right here okay
so what we have is we're trying to look
for c this length here so we've got c
squared equals
a squared which is the 3
mile squared plus the b squared which is
a 2 mile squared
minus 2 times 3 times 2
times the cosine of the angle that's in
between the two sides that they're
giving us so that's
10 degrees so what we're going to do is
we're going to input this on our
calculator and then because we're just
looking for c what we're going to do is
we're going to take the square root of
both sides so i'm going to go ahead and
do that now we can check our answer here
together in a moment so it's going to be
let's see 3 squared is 9 plus 2 squared
is 4 minus 2 times 3 times
2 times the cosine of 10 just make sure
your calculator is set to degrees since
this is in degrees
okay so that comes out to about 15.96
and if i take the square root of that
we're looking at 3.99 so i'm just going
to say approximately
four miles
so that's it that's the law of cosines
again just familiar familiarize yourself
with the formulas and just kind of see
the pattern that i was showing you here
originally about how the angle of side
are across from each other and then the
other two sides are what are going to be
these two quantities here see a and b a
and b or a and c a and c
so definitely something important to
understand i'll see in the next lesson